you uh you just tapped in with draco who
just got out
we just had him up here last week yeah
um you guys did the little boozy record
shot the video did you did you and draco
have a relationship prior to him getting
locked up
yeah because they before we was locked
up as kids
for like nine months and i was real
tight it was real close
he didn't rap at that time so you knew
him since you guys were kids you guys
were locked up together
in juvenile juvenile woods and they put
us in a foster care
um group home and was yup moves together
and [ __ ]
damn so you guys got a friendship
outside of this rapture yeah he bought
me i remember because
on the weekends they let you go with
your family on the weekends only friday
to sunday he came back on the whole pass
like i got you something he got me a
little gift it was my because i turned
well i turned 16 in there or some [ __ ]
he got me a's hat
oh yellow he said yeah that's crazy so
it was like
it's crazy because he got out and just
recorded like
that whole project yeah like in like in
like a week
and when i was locked up i had book
composition books all written you know
what i'm saying yeah so you're
not gonna like all of it but you want
like at least a good amount like where
you can put out
a couple projects and [ __ ] for sure